[Applause]
all right all right now let's let's
focus here everybody focus here let's be
honest I want everybody listening at
home I want y'all to be honest I want
everybody to be honest right now be
honest I'm not talking about that at all
I want everybody to be honest okay given
your safety would be intact and nobody
would see you there
would you go to the Trump rally in Tulsa
yes Lahoma akash says yes yeah I
remember nobody would know that you were
there your safety was intact yes just
experience I need to know what's going
on in there boom yes boom yeah I would
want to go see an experienced any
historical event that's like important
like regardless of how good or bad it is
but why is this in for an historical
event getting elected with his trumpet
let me talk about one specific well this
was Mississippi because all the stuff
around it like Juneteenth Tulsa Oklahoma
all that [ __ ] I mean this is I agree
with you he moved the date because he's
[ __ ] right keep going but like I would
go and I think that was the intention
the whole time I think he used that as a
way to get buzz for it and then jump
your next thing out son I should have
[ __ ] I I give it up to their marketing
I think their marketing is on point and
also I think it's like it's really funny
the way people reacted to the Juneteenth
thing because like if he was somebody if
he was a politician that you thought was
really like respectful of black people
and I cared about black people doing on
Juneteenth you beg you know how woke is
he he's doing it on the day slavery
anything's going to Tulsa Oklahoma no no
I know so it's like he's doing in this
place you know where black Wall Street
was burned down like this guy's for us
but the fact that everybody's like he's
racist it looks as like it's an
antagonistic act does that make sense so
you put whatever your views of Trump are
on to the situation instead of just
going this is what it is mm-hmm that
make sense yeah like if Obama did it
you'd be like yo he's awoke as black as
dude ever he would do this this is our
president but since Trump does it it's
like he hates us yeah it's the exact
same action yeah then why would he move
the date but
but of course you detentions are good
then don't move to date Joe he was like
yo I didn't know but there was this
thing called UT and this thing did
happen in Tulsa like he knew and he was
trying to rile up his base I think
that's what it was I think that it was
used I bet you they rented the ship for
both days I don't think his intention
was completely coincidental let's go to
Tulsa on Juneteenth I think he wants to
rebuild black Wall Street I think that's
his main black Wall Street great again
real talk blow the walls Brill the wall
but I would go and also go to Biden's
situation because it's like the same way
I look at me yeah I got a watch sign
then for a little bit and then I'll
watch Fox News when you go to bar like
sir this one yesterday he goes he goes
yo he goes he was because I'm basically
I'm saying this I'm a yo-yo nago too I
was like you know I want to go to I want
to witness it I think it'd be cool to
witness it you know he goes you know but
we got to go too
we got to go to Biden's too or would you
go to Biden's - are you interested in
going to binds to and I go nothing would
make me happier than to listen to that
old man babble in front of 20,000 people
and when I say that I'm describing both
of them but Biden's gonna say crazy [ __ ]
and Trump is gonna say crazy [ __ ] I
absolutely would love to go experience
both of them it is an interesting thing
you'd have to make sure your safety was
on point well if you rather Allan
particular [ __ ] yeah anyway look man you
guys let us know we love y'all we
appreciate y'all this episode is all
over the place as well alex is gonna do
some surgery to put this together sorry
for being late
yeah we're sorry for late we appreciate
y'all man thank you guys so much dude
we'll see you guys this Friday on
patreon obviously patreon.com slash
flagrant - come join we almost had
10,000 over there is crazy - growth man
we come in freeze [ __ ] those
spots ahead of us on we're coming for
top five spot man we're gonna come for
top spot five and we're gonna go top one
I really want to really want that patron
to just be the most mad if it was up to
me there be all of you guys that listen
to this episode regularly will also be
on a patreon let's create that [ __ ]
are
just move move culture with it man like
move ideas out there and just and just
keep [ __ ] [ __ ] up like we have that
as something we're really proud of man
so so you know go check that out you
love you we appreciate y'all and we'll
see you if not Friday next Tuesday yes
[Applause]